he's G rule, but there is a
lot that is riding on whatever
decision he makes.
>> Evan Perez, thank you so
much.
Let's talk about this all with
former Nixon white house
counsel, John Dean.
John, you know a little bit
about millions of American
households watching such a
proceeding.
The watergate hearings, of
course, we're not in a
courtroom.
It was more than 50 days of
broadcasts and administration
on trial.
What are your first thoughts
when you hear about this
televised hearing?
If you think it's a service or
a disservice to the cause of
justice?
>> I think it's a service.
I can tell you, from personal
experience, having been an 85
million households for a week,
that suddenly people understand
things that they didn't begin
to understand before.
That what will happen as a
result of this being televised.
That's one of the real issues
in whether or not this case is
removed two federal court.
It's not likely the federal
courts will televise it, it
would take an exception to the
rule to do so.
And while there are efforts to
make that happen in, I don't
think it will.
It's very difficult to get
those rules changed.
>> Well prosecutors for the
district attorney fani Willis
told a judge that the trial
could take four months, the
judge said today, he thought it
could easily be eight months.
Given the 19 defendants.
Do you think the American
people will have the attention
span for eight months,
potentially, 150 witnesses?
>> What happened during
watergate, and what happened
during the trials I've watched
on television, is interest
waxes and wanes.
It depends a lot of on the
witnesses to the issues.
There will be in and out of
issues.
There will be a few people, as
I've talked to some over the
years, who watch every single
day, every single hour.
And actually sometimes watch
replays.
By and large, the bulk of the
public will be in and out of
the proceedings.
They'll be there for them.
That's the important thing
that's why I think they should
be televised.
>> I remember, I was only five,
but I remember my mom watching
watergate on the little black
and white we had no living
room.
It was one of my first
memories.
District attorney Willis also
wants one massive trial for all
19 defendants, including trump,
she wants this on October 23rd. 19 defendants, plus, obviously,
they are council.
Just thinking about that,
sounds impossible.
In rather circus like.
>> Jake, it's hard to imagine
all 19 are gonna go to trial.
You know, they know the
consequences.
They are beginning to point
fingers at trump and each
other.
This is not likely to go on
mass.
Some will flip, some will do
deals, some will find other
ways to get out of this
situation.
I don't think all 19, our
nominee will go, but I can
understand why, as the
prosecutor, there are certainly
benefits to having all of them
there.
That happened in the watergate
trials that did happen, when
the former chief of staff,
Haldeman, the former top
domestic adviser, ehrlichman,
former attorney general, all of
those involved in the watergate
cover-up, were tried together.
I think there were several of
them in the courtroom.
Again, a witness for two weeks.
In that proceeding.
But there's an advantage to the
prosecutors having them there.
In the most effective witness,
excuse, me defendant, was one
who sat in a corner with nobody
else around and got no judgment
against them by the jury.
The jury thought that person
couldn't be involved.
So, there can be strategic
locations in mass trials like
this.
>> At one point during
watergate, you open names and
figures who, in your opinion,
had broken the law.
You were marked, quote, how in
god's name could so many
lawyers get involved in
something like this?
I'm wondering, if you look at
the list of Georgia defendants,
seven of the 19 defendants are
attorneys.
If you're wearing the same
thing.
>> I have been wondering the
same thing, particular since
I've tried to use watergate in
the last decade.
As a teaching .
For what lawyers should not do.
I've been out there and really
thought, maybe watergate had
had an impact.
Certainly, it required ethics
being taught in law schools.
Required a national ethics
exam.
Now, we've got how to examine
again whether indeed that is
worked or had an impact.
Or why it is that some lawyers
are inclined to so easily cross